okay okay go ahead suspension about the
doctors and the nurses yes working on
this stuff
you know in regards to healing
on the sabbath so say they weren't
getting paid on this sabbath would that
change things
you don't work on the sabbath okay jesus
said it's lawful to do good
he did not say it's lawful to work you
see if you excuse sabbath work which
gains pay then you must excuse the
firemen and you must excuse because they
have good arguments you must excuse the
policeman you may have to excuse the fbi
agent they quite if you have this fbi
agent the ten churches in washington dc
we cannot make an exception for any
commandment okay once you do that you
open the floodgates to make exceptions
for all the other nine
in it thou shalt not do any work
and trust god to take care of you
there's a reason why god did not send
manna on sabbath
manny means that which keeps your life
you understand because they complained
they were hungry they're about to die he
said man about not on sabbath which
means god does not provide a living on
the sabbath
as i said sometime you know to whom
if you make a living on the sabbath it
didn't come from god
it did not come from god
the devil can give you things don't
misunderstand me but it did not come
from god yes can you